well hello okay thank you very much for
coming
I'm slightly surprised to see anyone
here because this is essentially
something you will never ever want to do
so we are going to be talking about
almost every detail you need to get to
get dotnet code running from scratch and
I would say if you ever thinking about
how to solve a problem you think I know
I'll write my own dotnet runtime
I would highly recommend you go away and
think about it again
Microsoft did this very well
there is no reason for anyone else to do
this now of course if you're thinking oh
it might be fun to write my own down
there runtime that's a completely
different matter and I would highly
recommend giving it a go because it was
quite fun in a very kind of nice techie
sort of way and that's exactly the kind
of people I hope you are because this is
very neat very techy I will be going
into as I say just about everyday
detail of how to do this whether we can
do that in one hour is yet to be
discovered
so excitement for all of us here so I'm
Chris bacon my day job is I work for
Google in the cloud net team along with
John and some other people this is
nothing to do with that Google at Google
we are not writing our own down there
runtime janta made that very clear
this is this is totally not Google word
not yet yes who no no as far as May
there are no plans to do so either okay
so let's get going so just to be clear
on what we're going to do I have a
visual studio I have Visual Studio open
here on the right I hope you can see
that we have a couple of projects here
we have a classic hello world this is a
c-sharp project which has oh let's
shrink that font size slightly which has
considerable own hello world and what
we're gonna try and do is write a
program in C naught C sharp
see that can take the dll produced by
the c-sharp compiler and execute that
code now this actually is too difficult
is too ambitious too complicated so what
we're actually going to do is we're
going to take this code and execute that
and you will see this is still fairly
complicated but this is I hope
manageable right so we're going to build
that now I've already set up a build
rule to copy the screw to pull into the
correct place and yet the correct place
is the same directory as this C file
here now I'm not an expert in C I
haven't done a lot of C for many many
years
so I apologize up front if my idioms are
wrong my casings are wrong my whatever
is wrong please don't tell me about it
maybe at the end you can come and
criticize my C but it's not something I
do any more regularly so I have here a C
file now the talk did say this was going
to be from scratch and but you can see
there is already code here the code here
is very minimal and it's actually almost
completely type def struct definitions
rather than actual code so we are
basically going to write all the code
from nothing at all so just to quickly
whisk through what's here we've got some
standard includes we've got a few macros
that I'll describe later we have a
function called crash which just print
out an error message and exits and then
we have a whole load of Struck's and the
type death to the drugs and some more
macros and then again as you can see a
struct off the struct after struct and
we'll come to what these are in a moment
the reason i've defined them predefined
them is because it's just a bit tedious
copying them out of the specification
and if you guys forget it's wrong
it all goes horribly wrong very very
quickly and then there's this this quick
array here which again the numbers are
important if I get it wrong it's all
very embarrassing for everyone so I've
pre done that so this is our actual code
that we're starting with if you don't
know C hopefully this very clear I'll
just run it and tada press ENTER to exit
there we go it works good news right so
let's make a start now
the the document you need to do this is
the ECMO standard 335 this is the full
tedious and detailed specification of
how dotnet works exist the CLI
partitions 1 to 6 and if we reach down
to the contents you can see you've got
constant architecture which is good to
read just to get a general idea you then
got all the details of metadata
semantics silly instruction set so the
SIL instruction set still stands for
common intermediate language right yes
and that is what the c-sharp compiler
actually produces it produces SIL so
when we say you know x equals 1 it
produces sorry VAR x equals 1 they
produces the the il to execute that ok
so this is a very detailed document
there's all kinds of stuff in the
contents that we're not going to talk
about and that's not the point I'm not
going to explain some of what what I'm
going to do because there isn't enough
time so some of it I will explain as I
go along other bits I hope just kind of
pick up as we go along ok so this is the
dog and this is a directory where main
dot C is and as I say I've set it up to
copy hello world DLL to that directory
and when we run this I've arranged it
inverted to do that it passes hello
world DLL as a parameter so the first
thing we do right here we go
C coding there's gonna be a lot of it I
hope you enjoy it right we need to load
that file so we're going to load the
file and we're going to pass it our p1
which and see the the offset 1 is the
first parameter of Z naught is the name
of the executable there's actually
running so we need now to write a thing
that loads file so we have a mythical
low file which currently returns nothing
but it will return something later on
we're gonna load the file and just to
see what we're doing
and just to prove we'll just run that to
prove that we are passing in writes ok
low file hello a DLL right so late a
file from disk how do you do that told
you we're going to start a scratch doing
everything we first of all open the file
we say want to read it it's a binary
file and we want to have read access to
it that returns an int file descriptor
we then need to find the length of the
file this is a little bit tedious we
could map it but map isn't portable and
I can never remember the windows way of
memory mapping things so instead we we
seek to the end to find the link we then
seek back the beginning to find let's go
back at the beginning we then allocated
some data I'm using malloc because it
hits C so we have to actually allocate
data for the right length we then read
the file contents and then because I'm a
good citizen we close the file ok so
that now has load the file into a memory
program now executable files in Windows
have ever since the ms-dos days
contained a marker at the begin the file
which is MZ which apparently were the
initials of a very early investors
programmer I didn't who they were so
what we can do is we can just verify
that this file does have those those
those values so we will say now little
by my macros Val all it does is it takes
a memory pointer a pointer which in this
case T P data offset 0 cast the result
to a pointer to chart and then
dereference is the the pointer so it
means I can read a value at a particular
offset from a memory pointer without
having to worry about types and other
inconvenient things so this one should
be M and we're gonna do is going to
crash if this isn't right and this one
that should be Zed oops said capitals in
okay say that's good and then if we and
now we know isn't it suitable if Miss
Grimes and we just run that and it isn't
it's good for excellent we've passed the
first hurdle good news right so now the
question is what do we do
we've got this big blob of memory that
somehow contains that that c-sharp
program but how do we run it so we turn
to the manual and this is the part we
need second to second 25 the structure
of the runtime file format so let's go
here right so we start off with an
ms-dos header as I explained which has
the MZ that's 14 5a and then the thing
we need this is Elif a new pointer here
and this is a pointer that tells us
where the next sort of header is in this
file so we're gonna say LF a new your
cause and again using our macro to read
an int from now I will actually just
define a P ms-dos header which is the
same as the data cuz it starts officer
zero in the file but it just makes it
slightly clearer that which which header
we're currently reading into so if I
knew plus no sorry sorry I think you
equals that and then the offset we need
to read it from is three C in this file
as the manual told us so we read that
and now we have an NFA new and as the
manual says but if you can read that to
make it slightly bigger and unsigned
integer off everything new to the PE
header the PE header is the portable
execution header so that's what we're
gonna go next so we're going to make a
pointer to the PE header and I've
another macro which just allows me to
get a pointer at a particular offset now
we're going to be plus 4 because the
first four bytes the P header are does
PE null null which are not interesting
so we're gonna give you those very good
and now we want to check no you're not
gonna look at the definition of the PE
header which is yeah and you can see
here the first thing that looks
interesting is
the offset zero that should be value
that's always a fixed value so we can
check that so now we can say if Val
we've got the P header and it's a short
cuz it's a two by two thing that's right
yep
so the size there is two bytes offset
zero so that's a short so we read a
short frumpy header at all so it's zero
and if that is not the value specified
which is one for C and X then we crash
and say this is not a don't net but
don't let executable terrible news but
if it if it is 1 for C then we say it is
a net XC q bull that's big smiley right
whoops there we go right so again we can
now run that and see if it succeeds it
succeeded its next eautiful and it's a
dot next feed for good news now I've
forgotten to put the carriage turns on
the end get to used to write line in
c-sharp ok so just run that and there we
are it's no suitable and it is it done
executable good news ok right we now
have to go and look at what comes next
so immediately after the PS signature is
P file headed we should just looked at
it then goes into a padi serve out some
of these flags that we're not interested
in I should say we're doing the absolute
minimum necessary here to get to the
Ashley executing code we will do nothing
and let's be have tea and that means
we're not verifying anything we're not
error checking we're not doing anything
like that that you would normally do
right immediately followed off the PE
header is the PE optional header right
and so immediately following so we can
go and look at this and see this is 20
bytes long the PE header so we can now
say the PE optional header it's a
pointer that starts at the MS DOS header
but at an officer of 20 and so that
point macro just just let you get
pointers offset all the pointers
yes you may be right thank you
great so we now have the optional header
and then also if we just whisk down a
bit further we can see there is a where
that there's another header we need
called the PE a section header which
actually I think we'll get to in just a
moment and back at the P header the only
other bit we need from this PE header is
this number of sections and I'll explain
what this is in just a moment and why we
want it so we will get a variable an int
which contains the number of sections in
this far now a section is to do with how
data is represented in these sp4 files
so there's split up into sections and
then the addressing is kind of on a
section relative addressing which we'll
come to in a moment
so no sections it's a short it's at and
the PE header and it's offset to great
so now we can print out how many
sections we have
okay excellent let's run that again
and we should have a central number
sections we do three it seems reasonable
right so now we need to load the
sections so we will loop through all the
sections I did warn you every detail was
going to be gone through so this is one
of those details so each section
contains a bit of memory that we've
loaded in the file and then it has like
a virtual base address and then all
future addressing is via that virtual
base address not the actual kind of
offset in the file so we find a pointer
to the section oh no before that we need
to get the section header so which
follows the optional header so we have
the section section headers and the
headers because they're just
sequentially in memory they're not
there's no indexing into them they're
just sequential so that say we need to
find out how long the optional header is
and then it's just after the optional so
the optional header is you can see is
there's something at offset and i6 that
has a size of 128
so what's 96 plus 128 that's 224 so the
offset from the optional header of 224
that is the section header right so to
load the first section we have a pointer
from the section header or it's going to
look at what the second header is first
of all now down here somewhere
we have the section header definition
right so here you can see each section
header has a format following total of
40 bytes per section header and this is
the content so I would say virtual
address is and the pointer to the raw
data so we have to kind of copy some
data around so we can access it later
right P optional header so we're going
to do I times 40 because the optional
not awful header sorry
section headers these section headers so
we create a pointer to this section
header this section right we then have
to I've got a structure already defined
could off yet no obvious answer a
relative virtual address and it just
contains the base address the size and
then the actual pointer to where we're
going to store them everywhere Malick's
and meta soms and memory environment and
then peanuts because we create a linked
list of the all the RV A's or VA
sections rather so if each one we create
a struct nugget a handy macro that
generates that Alex memory for a
particular struct and returns a pointer
to it we then need to go wait you might
be thinking crumbs have already been
going for quarter of now and all we've
done is this I must tell you that
unfortunately exciting that will be when
we get to actually executing code it's
only a small part of what we have to do
to get there and this is all the getting
there so right well carry on getting
there so we need to set the base address
which as you can hear as this is this
virtual address and these are the
addresses at the rest of the file uses -
oops say we set the base address to the
virtual address which is odd offset
twelve and a size for size an integer so
we have an integer P section and as off
at twelve wasn't it yeah at twelve we
set the size to again that's here
virtual size officer eight is an integer
P section offset eight we now we
actually set the data now we now know
the size of it so we will we will now
we're going to connect this which clears
the memory to zero and the reason we're
doing that is because the some times the
size of the the claimed size of the
section is not actually the size of the
raw data and we want it zero filled so
that we don't end up with garbage in our
in our data and correct Priya zero fills
it we're then going to
you get the ahve offset which is this
pointer to raw data here so that's
offset 20 it's an integer so again we
use our handy macro to get it what's it
opposite 20 and now we do a memory copy
to copy that data into the area which is
allocated so the destination is the
memory of dis allocated the source is
the offset who we've just read the ave
offset and it's the offset into the
entire file from the beginning of the
file which is why we've done it from P
data and then we need to the size now
unfortunately for reasons I don't
understand you have to take the minimum
of the claimed ERV a size and the and
the size of the raw data it can be
either one rather can be larger than
those so that's a offset a 16 okay so
we've done the memory copy and now we
just connect up our link list so we say
ah but where are we storing this stuff
good question what we actually need to
do is keep a record of everything we've
know about this file so I just happen to
have a struct called T file so we'll
have a pointer to that now T file as you
can say we have a pointer to all the
r-va is and this is the head of the
linked list that we're about to generate
I'll talk about the other stuff soon so
we need to allocate so we'll allocate
one of these and now we can use that to
store our r.v A's so there's a IV over
to next and this is just how it's going
at a linked list because we've collected
it's the initial P file that prva s is
null so that's correct
and then we just need to connect up the
linked list so we're doing is realistic
in each section in the beginning of the
linked list so now we have loaded our
sections good news right let's run that
instead of crashes coefficient
it doesn't number section 3 we've loaded
our sessions
so what next
we've now kind of got our memory in a
way that we can now use it when later on
we're told to go and read an RV a
address we can now we now know our of
EA's go to the base addresses sorted out
so now we need to move on so so far we
haven't done anything to do with
with.net at all really we've just been
filling around with memory and headers
but we're about to move on something
where we are dealing with CLI things
because we get to this CLI header so the
next thing we do is load and look out
this CLI header so the first of all
question is how do we get the address of
the CLI header it's in the file
somewhere and the way we do that is this
entry here so offset 208 in the PE
header we have listener header now you
notice as 8 bytes long so what is this
and the answer is touch up here each
data entry contains the r-va
now that's what we've just been playing
with that's why we need these RVs and
the size so both those are four by tents
so basically the first four offset 208
the first four bytes is the r-va address
and then the next four bytes is the size
we're going to ignore the size and just
just read the r-va address so let's load
the CLI header so we'll have a pointer
oops
pointer to the CLI header and now we
need to load the RV address now how do
we do that well we're gonna write a
method called let find fine RV a find
data so we give it the file this doesn't
exist yet we're gonna write it in a
moment
what was it we wanted we wanted an
integer from the which header was it
data directory oh yes yes so that's
actually part of this thing called the
the PE is actually the optional header
yes one the section of this optional
header says part of this optional header
so I'll head up at offset 208 yes okay
so now we need to go and write this RV a
fine data method so we're going to be
returning a pointer and we need to take
a tiff file reason me to file this
because that's where the of EA's are
stored and then we have the address so
what does this look like well we need to
whisk through this linked list so we
start at the head it's a bit tedious
having to Codel this by hand but that
was the promise of this talk come on
while you're doing that and then while
prva doesn't get to the linked list i
can't type and if we can't find it we
will just return now possibly we should
crash I'm not quite sure
oh yes oh yes yes yes thank you as I
said I've done C for a while and this is
a very simple comparison so if the
address is anywhere within the header we
have to return the correct memory
address that is kind of where that would
be so we just say if prva will say if
address is greater or equal to prva base
address and address is less than the
base address plus the size then we've
got the right one so then we return so
we have to return the our VAP data but
then we have to return the correct
offset so it's however far the address
was into that structure
now I'm just going to make sure I get
this right
right so we returned then we were this
pointer macro which it gives us the
correct offset into here so it's a is
the address - the base address of this
section okay so that that's done that's
good news
so now we can load we've got the CLR
header from the r-va now the next thing
to do is look in this CLI header and
there's some interesting things in this
year I hit up that look very kind of
starting to look familiar the kind of
things that we'd expect
so major runtime version minor runtime
version let's print those out so runtime
version and these are they're both
shorts they're offset four and six so we
need short into the CLI header the
offset floor wasn't it yep before is the
major version and six is the minor
version so we'll just print out these
two things and let's run that and that's
about a header on the game and so that
says
ah it's nothing at all so that means
it's one we're certainly got a bug in
our find our VA oh yes it's I know I did
if you go to that I made the elementary
for mistake of forgetting to move on to
the next item in our link list right
it's let's run that and they were a
runtime version 2.5 which I must MIT I'm
a bit vague on runtime versions but it
seems about right
what ah
that comes later the other 4.0 you will
get there right so that's the runtime
version and yes that's the CLI version
which would be the 4.0 then ask me the
semantics of that I didn't quite name
right so we've got the runtime version
now this thing here the entry point
token now the entry point of a program
is the usually the kind of where you
start running the program so this looks
important what is a token we'll come to
that later but for the moment we'll just
we'll just record that now we all we
happen to have something to store this
in our T filed a structure and it's just
an integer so we will use our normal
method of reading integers and store
that into the T file structure so isn't
it see I had her and it's offset is 20
and this an inch as I said so we'll do
that and we'll just print it out because
it's quite interesting entry point token
now we're going to print it as hex
because that proves its interest
okay we're gonna run that so there we
are into point taken six lots of zeroes
one now this this a token is something
about how net metadata is stored within
the file and what comfortable will need
to come please a bit more or face soon
but basically the the most significant
byte which is the six tells you what
which table and will come to table soon
which table this refers to and then the
other 24 bits are which entry in this
table is it so its entry one in Table
six and we'll learn more about that very
soon right so we've got an inch point
taken and now we need to move on to the
actual what was called the metadata so
we have here an RV a and size two
physical metadata now the metadata is
literally everything about your program
is stored in what are called metadata
tables so every method every type every
parameter every field every everything
else you can think of they're storing
metadata tables so what we're now going
to do is load the metadata got a pointer
to the metadata header and then we will
have to read through some of this
metadata just enough that we can get
what we need to execute the wonderful
exciting program we're trying to execute
so the first thing we'll do is get a
pointer to the metadata so PMF later and
again if you look this isn't our VA so
we use our our VA find data method
that's our file and the address is right
is the offset eight into the CLI header
so we see my header comma eight okay so
that's that loaded is that right no no
silly me I've forgotten to actually use
these are macro right that's better
all right that should that should build
go with sortie bugging yes was totally
buggin
and they're done I think I've just done
this wrong yeah that's you been int okay
right so that's now got a pointer to our
master data and we're going to exactly
what the meta is very soon and now
because if we go down to this definition
of metadata header which is nowhere is
this is this right here we are this is
in section 24 so this is the this is the
metadata header and one thing that's
worth showing here is this version and
this is the CLI version but this expects
to run on so we can printf CLI version
so yes as a string and this fortunately
is utf-8 we'll just assume it's ASCII
which it is in this case so that means
we can just print it rightly it's a
minute of clips clips just made that the
char star and we use our pointer macro
to just get an offset of 16 because
that's where it is offset 16 into our
metadata hello and so now if we print if
we run that right version 4.0 points 3
or 3/1 night now this is much more you
may have seen that kind of number when
you're playing with dotnet code so we
really are getting to stuff that's now
much more familiar it's taking a while
there's been quite a few kind of twisty
paths but we're sort of getting there
that's good news okay however I have to
tell you the most fiddly and annoying
bed is still to come but it won't take
too long to get through it now the
reason it's frilly and annoying is
because of reasons of making sure the
file is as small as possible there's now
a whole load of headers that just follow
sequentially after each other but
they're all variable length and there's
no indexing into them so unfortunately
we now do have to like do some nasty
pointer arithmetic and just keep track
of where we are in headers and all that
kind of stuff so I'll get through that
as quickly as possible so hopefully in
10 minutes we should be through that but
it's quite interesting seeing the kind
of stuff at these headers contain
and well let's just do it and then we'll
your see so we've just uh listen uh
right so here we are verbal link stuff
the version is a variable length string
so now you'll notice the offsets are not
just simple numbers they're now things
like a 16 plus m 16 plus X plus X plus 2
noise kind of stuff so we now have to
kind of keep incrementing pointers to or
offsets to keep track of where we are in
strings so the first week you notice how
long was that version that version
string and fortunately it tells us
offset 12 we have an integer that
contains the links or that version
string here's to see I had a still so
we'll get the version length by reading
an integer into our metadata header
opposite 12 we will now keep track of an
offset so this is an offset into all
these headers which we will initialize
that 16 plus the version length and
that's because you'll notice that the
variable length thing is at 16 we're
gonna add the version length now
fortunately the version length already
contain all these dealt with padding so
we don't thought about that so now we
are here so offset now contains 16 plus
X we now need to know how many streams
are there now I'm not gonna I don't know
why the cross streams particularly and
very soon what you'll learn what this
means so we know how many streams there
are and that's a 16 plus X plus 2 but OC
suppose X is officer plus 2 so we're
gonna find the stream count so that's
again it's a short because it yep that's
a 2-byte numbers as a short and we're p
metadata and off set it off set passed
it to you it's let it print out our
stream count just to make sure that it
looks sane
okay oops it's not important but I'm
perfectionist okay and we run this and
there should be five streams and there
are and there are essentially always
five streams and we'll come on well
actually I can quickly show you and the
streams are right stream header right
these are the streams strings heap the
US and blob heaps that gooood heap and
the tilde stream which is by followers
complicated in the most difficult to
deal with but we have to we'll talk
about what are these streams are for in
a moment we're only going to have to
worry about the tilde stream and the
strings heap right so for each stream
we're now going to increment the offset
by four because as we lost track where
we were which farm where were we I think
we're in here well me yes so that gives
us access to the streams headers which
is what we now need to do through the
each stream has a header that we're now
going to read to find out what stream it
is and where the data is associated with
that stream in the file so we are
literally going to for loop through each
stream okay so we need to find the
stream offset and in the header here you
can see the offset is offset zero and
it's an integer so we read an integer
from the metadata whatever offset we've
now got to the next thing is the stream
size we ask you don't care about that
not gonna verify our stream is
maintaining the size but we will just
read it because it's quite nice just
print it out so we can just check that
everything looks the same so it's offset
plus four
we now need the stream name which is
here it's a name of the stream as null
terminator variable length array of
ascii characters and pathogen later for
like the boundary with nulls so we get a
stream name char pointer which is in the
metadata which is just pointer offset
plus 8 because that's a off state
right and now we write and now we
actually want to get so the stream
offset we have here this integer this is
an offset into the from the metadata
header of where the actual stream dat
reeze so let's get a pointer to that so
stream this is call it a stream and it's
a pointer so we it's based on the
metadata pointer but it's a stream
offset bytes past the beginning of the
message ID head okay we now need to
increment our offset for the next cycle
around the loop and then we'll actually
look at these these values now the
offset increment is a pain it's the 8
bytes of these two things plus its
variable length thing here so 8 plus the
padding so 8 plus and we get the length
the I know strings unsafe I don't care
will get the length of the string we add
for for padding and then we end it by
the negation of 3 and that that does the
padding correctly so that it pads it out
to 4 bytes so that's that that's our
loop will now loop through all the
streams and let's just print out what
stream as we found so we have a stream
name and we should find that these
stream names here hash good hash us has
probably things now we found those
streams hopefully if we've got our
pointers right we have looking at we
found all the correct streams as
expected victory it may feel like a
small victory but we are getting there
whoo good news right say what are we
going to do with these streams well we
have treating me differently so we will
now do a if a nice stroke accomplished
again is unsafe thing care if if a
street name is now unfortunately have I
got my keyboard map correct I have good
we're gonna have to do with this tilde
stream now this is one that contains all
what I called the metadata tables
right so the question is what are
metadata tables well let's go to the
documentation right here so this is the
definition of all what are called
metadata logical format tables so
there's a whole lot of things in here
some of which will you can kind of think
oh yeah I can see why that would be
needed in in in add on there that's cute
for so some obvious ones method def this
is a method definition so let's just go
and look at the details of what this
actually contains it contains an RV a
now to what you might ask well if we
just whizzed down here it tells us so it
seriously r-va here we are know if our
v8 cause Norton either was an option I
said 12 a does not equal naught and let
me to me it's bigger then RV a shall
point to the sill code stream in this
file yes
finally we found some il-2 it's cute
we have initially found it yet but we
now have that we're reading the right
documentation so this is really good
news so back up to what else here
there's some flags there's more flags
there's a name and yes that really is
the name of the method and then there's
what's called a signature now the
signature is everything apart from the
name that defines its method so it's
like what the return type is what the
premise types are any generic
constraints all that and stuff we're not
going to care about signatures at all in
what we're doing today and then it
contains an entry into the parameters so
that you can find out about the
parameters like the names the parameters
the types all that kinda stuff and the
order of the parameters right so how do
you load these tables we do it by going
and looking at the documentation yet
again where were we that's about a
stream right hit the tilde stream yes so
this is the so the data we've got for
the toda stream points to this structure
and we don't care about any of this
apart from the first thing we care about
is valid so they can be up to 64 table
valid is an 8 byte 64 bit number and
it's just a bit for
old saying which tables are valid in
this particular file so they've me up to
64 tables in this father will be nowhere
near suitable so we need to go through
this bit field finding out which tables
are valid and then the first minute is
find out the length of all these tables
and as you can see this entry down here
tables this is the sequence of physical
tables but who actually contains its
first of all it contains a list of all
the lengths of valid tables then it
contains the actual date in the tables
so the first we have to do is find out
all the links for the tables which we
will do so long long valid so we first
will read that valid header which is a
long long which doesn't see it that's
how you do a suitable bit number there's
probably other ways but this is one way
and that's what officer ate there it is
we then have to get a pointer to a row
counter pointer so as I said the first
thing it contains is the length of the
tables which is a officer at 24 so we go
find a pointed officer 24 and we have
they're all in the length of the tables
so we use int and now we have a for loop
through so we'll have a couple of
variables here we'll start j at 1 which
is the bit I was counting how many bits
and J is the the bit mask so you cyclist
here and we say if valid and J so it
means if this is a valid table then we
record something about it so in the pay
file but also had an entry for these
tables which is a 64-bit assist for
entry array of counts and pointers so we
in this sort of live through we set the
count and the count is wherever the
integer the road count pointer is
pointing to and then we have to
increment the row counter but only for
valid tables now you might say if you
don't see doing a plus equals one
doesn't encumbered amount by two
increments it by one or whatever it's
pointing to and I said we're pointer in
so that's going to increment it by four
bytes so that's now got the length
that's good news and now we actually
laid the data so we have table data
because Piro counter because the table
eight starts where the row counter the
row entry is finish
or print something out we'll print that
we've know he's going to print out as he
as we load each table we're going to
print out something about it so we'll
just print out that start with lesson
six four again it can be up suitable
tables so we cycle through your suit
four times we look in our previously
stored area to find out how many rows
there are in each table and if count
does not equal naught then we need to
load this table so first of all we look
at the table size which is right there
just how many bytes each entry in the
table takes now this is I've had a bit
of a shortcut here because if you go and
look at some of these definitions of
method def example this is what's in the
table so we have a four byte constant a
2-byte flag another two by flag and then
a name it doesn't tell you how many
bytes it is why would they do that
and the answer is is because it's
variable but it's variable in a very
constrained way so it's either 16 or 32
bits depending on how many entries are
in this table so if there are more than
2 to the 16 entries it'll be a 32 bit
it's as fewer it'll be 16 bit we're only
dealing with small files so they're
always going to be 16 bits in this case
so I've hard coded 16 bits you can't do
that in a real a real system but that
means that I know at compile time the
size of all my tables or so I've just
stuck those in an array and that was one
of the arrays I showed you the beginning
I said it's important these are right so
that's the table size right we're then
going to allocate some we're going to
allocate some memory to store the right
we need a pointer for each entry in the
table and we're going to do a plus 1
because the table tokens have 1 based
indexing not zero based so it's quite
handy just to know if to worry about
that and we'll set the first entry the
0th entry to null right we now need to
go through each item in the table
and copy it to the right place now you
might ask why doing this tool why didn't
we just not copy it anywhere and the
answer is that we need to throw a little
bit of extra information along with each
item in the table so we unfortunately we
need to have somewhere to store the
extra information there our first words
are doing it I chose to do this way now
the prefix is that very is the extra
information we want to store so we need
to allocate something that's got the
size the prefix plus the table size
which is the size of a changing the
table and then we're just going to set
the the only thing we actually want to
know is the file that this table entry
came from so we store that in the prefix
and then we have to memory copy now
again P plus 1 that just skips past
however large the prefix is and then our
tape table data is our incrementing
pointer of where we are throughout this
mess data and you copy the table size so
that's good that's done we then oops we
then set so we've got an array that
contain all the pointers of its data so
now set that to prefix it's not just a
prefix it contains the prefix plus all
the data it's just and then we need to
increment our table data pointer it's a
void pointers if we can't add to it and
what we need to do is add on the size of
this particular table so that's done so
we've now loaded all our data and we
will triumphantly print out the fact
that we have loaded table ID whatever
and we will show how many entries we
have in each table so it stabilizes I
from the outer loop here that we're
iterating over and it's count which was
how many entries we have now if it's all
correct and this is where it could have
been horribly wrong because there's a
lot of point free stuff no but there we
are
so we've loaded those tables and that
tells you how many entries are off so
just quickly Table six is the method
death table
and you can see we've got two entries in
our method death that means within the
hello world program that we compiled
using the c-track compiler we have two
methods you might say two methods how
can that be
there's only one method in your program
but of course this is a non-static class
so the compiler has also generated a
constructor for us that's the other
method so when it says method def it
literally means it doesn't just mean
what we think of as methods it also
means constructors and static
constructors or class constructors well
yes running out of time so I'm not gonna
do that and we still haven't actually
any code right so but this is really
good news so we've done we're done we
can now return our file somebody's going
to change the signature of this method
to return a T file pointer and we need
to store the file oh we have loaded a
file yes we now have 12 minutes left to
execute something in this file but the
good news is that was the hardest bit of
this by a long way so now we really can
get on to more interesting things
although that was quite interesting I
thought it's not uninteresting now
organize all my paperwork here I did
take the low-tech solution of printing
out the actual code so I wouldn't have
to remember every single every single
bit as I was going along right remember
we loaded an entry point token that
tells us what method we need to run
first so we need to load an entry point
load the entry point method so we will
do that now
remember I'll show you the method death
stuff so this is a type I pre rope just
to represent that method def stuff so we
all have entry point method Def and we
will call a method that doesn't yet
exist cool get method by token and we'll
pass it the file that contains oh if I
know they do that sorry we'll pass it
the
entry point o in obedience right yes I
mean you pass it the file and the token
right so let's write this method you're
gonna be returning one of them whoops
pointer to it so we have a T file let me
have a method token so how's this gonna
work well we need to find which need to
load the right table entry for this
token now a method token we've looked a
method death but there's also another
way of referencing methods called method
ref which is where you want to reference
a method that is not in your dll and
obviously you can't doubt the method def
because you don't have il for it so
there's another way there's another
table called method ref that we're not
going to use but the token could be a
method ref talker not a method depth
akin so what we do is we're going to
extract the table ID from the method
token and then if it is a table ID
method def which is 6 then we can just
return now this this macro is or it does
it just it just goes to the correct end
table in the file and and gets me there
already loaded method def in this case
from there and then of course if that's
wrong we'll just crash because I can't
deal with it
we'll say return null because the
compiler complains if you don't return
for a method okay so now we've we've
loaded that method check it build if I
made a mistake I've made a mistake
I'm like I'm wrong
it's all good no errors so that's great
so what we can now print the name of
this method which is quite quite nice an
entry point method name right so we have
our P entry method F and look we have a
name name index what does that mean it
means remember the streams we were
talking about earlier when we loaded the
file
it means it's an index into the hash
strings stream so to read that we will
[Music]
use another macro called get string
where we passed the file we pass at the
offset and that will give us the correct
pointer trial point about which points
there is now conveniently these are
utf-8 strings at a null terminated in
the file so we can just reference
already utf-8 we'll pretend they're
asking now it won't work because we
didn't actually do with the string
stream here so what do that now so if
the stream name equals or was it hash
strings and equals naught means equal
then we'll do in the P file has a P
strings pointer so we'll just do that so
now we've recorded by the string stream
styles in the kind of file data now if I
run this you should print out the name
of our entry method and it does main how
about that and look look
it really was called main you take all
this for granted okay good right so well
next we are so close to executing code
so we have the entry point method loaded
we've got a reference to the method def
for it so what means do now what we need
to do now is when you execute code you
have to execute that on some kind of
state that keeps track of things like
where you are in the code in fact that's
all you track off to the moment so we're
going to call a method
would create method state and this is
going to create message state for this
entry point method that we've that we've
just loaded so we need to define this
method earlier obviously return
something in a moment
we'll worry about that in a moment TM DF
method death beam method death right so
what it means to create a method state
so the method state right we need to
have a type a struct which is our method
state and what we gonna need we're going
to need a pointer to the il we're going
to need an instruction pointer that's an
offset into the il of where we are and
possibly that's what we need we need
locals John says you haven't got any
locals who cares about make rules
we'd also keep a reference to the file
which I think we might need later okay
shop there isn't much later to going but
and we'll just time death that
okay so this is actually going to return
a tea method state pointer so first of
all we'll create method staked point
method state tema third estate because T
my handy McCrae to create one of them
okay so how do we how do we how do we
load this stuff that's a good question
and let me just double check how to do
that okay so we have to go through a
thing called the aisle header now
fortunately if you're thinking oh no not
another header it's a very simple item
so in the file we look up the IP address
of the OVA which has to be discovered
earlier is the address of the il header
now the aisle header right this is the
aisle header there are two types of
aisle header a tiny one or a fact one so
I get unfortunate naming we're only
gonna have to do with a tiny header
which is just 1 byte long and in fact
I'm not even going to check that it is
the tiny header I promise you it is so
method state pil is simply one byte
after the I our head that's right one
excellent and in fact that's all we need
to do we collect it so the instruction
pointer is already 0 so we can just
return that method I mistake so that's
good so we have a method state when able
to store that tea method
state equals great a mess state and now
we can execute it so we execute tea
method state ok how do you execute il
well and this is an interpretive runtime
so all we do we just read it up codes
execute them one at a time so we have an
infinite loop to go through the opcodes
we load an opcode right so this is an
unsigned char we're loading it for now
I'm trying to create a quick pointer
straight to the il that that's immutable
so we can just get a copy of that easily
enough any won't change and then the
offset is the instruction point to the
construction point so let's just print
out what we've now we're gonna print
this out as a two digit hex and here we
have your code and then what we're gonna
do is have a big switch a small switch
statement on the opcode which of course
by default it will just crash and say
cannot yet
execute opcode okay slight duplication
there but nevermind okay so let's run
this
I'm not thinking my linter down there oh
sorry nope e-file is just a tea farm
pick file
we don't need file oh that's what you
mean yes thank you thank you thank you
that should be a pee method great oh no
it's prefix P file oh come on come on
prefix doc P far there we are okay does
that build it builds does it run
it runs Oh except it doesn't print all
over them
Oh - thanks right try to get them I'm
still running right run and how about
that we can't ask you top code to a what
is OP code to a yeah we to ask me we
like within one minute of finishing so
okay to a is if we get a I or spy where
I've conveniently already laid this main
method so we're going to get the ellipse
and all that we're gonna look at the IRS
c-sharp and you notice just one
instruction return which is o X 2 a so
and that's defined here and then it's to
find it in the documentation here you
can see ret hasn't opcode to a so we
will make it so we can execute to a
and what you do with return you return
so ladies and gentlemen I present to you
a fully running Il interpreter from
scratch thank you thank you that was
quite intense but I hope it demonstrates
to you that this stuff which we
completed for granted we don't normally
know or care how it works but actually
it's not that complicated you can count
it up in an hour as I've just
demonstrated and although the only
instruction we can currently execute is
return it actually it's a shame we
didn't have another ten minutes because
we had it's surprisingly easy now to get
a subset of SIL executing like all the
automatic stuff for integers it's just
trivial completely trivial the next
thing I was actually if we had like two
more minutes I would have shown just
returning an exit code from a program
which the mint would have loaded a
constant integer and returned it and
then got out at the end and we could
have displayed our AC code so it's not a
complicated however having said all that
because we've ignored so much like we
don't have a type system at all let
alone one that can handle generics we
don't have a heap at all you can't load
other assemblies at all so all this
stuff is actually it does build up the
complexity but it is completely possible
for one person to write a pretty
complete il interpreted runtime in a few
months and I know that because I did it
a few years ago it's never been used
oh well no was used as it was used as a
prototype and then if I come across
blazer which is this new c-sharp and a
browser thing so their prototype used my
runtime in their prototype they don't
use anymore but it was quite satisfying
they did initially say thank you very
much for coming if you want to talk
about anything including questioning my
sanity
then do come and talk to me at the end
thank you very much for coming
[Applause]